it's a monday pft p.m first day of our
three-week hiatus no days off and really
all i'm doing is sitting here in my
office talking we have a new location
for the pft pm studio we did it in the
barn for a while it's a little warm down
there in the summertime i used to do the
vod segments when pft live was off the
air up in my studio but that's too far
of a walk
just where i sit where i am i can do
these every weekday and i will be doing
them to go over some of the topics that
are happening in the nfl and there is
still plenty of news in the nfl and i've
got a tiny little bit of news i had my
annual physical today that's why i've
been fairly scarce posting content at
pft get a physical every year if you're
over 40 even if you're under 40 it can't
hurt you get blood work
you get certain examinations that are
specific to your gender especially if
you're over 40 you get a stress test
they check out everything and it gives
you that peace of mind going into the
next year especially for me going into
football season
i feel like i'll be healthy until the
next physical even though i know that
you know something can happen between
now and then
i still feel like that checkup every
summer is the thing that gives me peace
of mind to carry through a year and i
think peace of mind is highly underrated
especially in light of the
collective lack of peace of mind that
we've had during the pandemic it was the
first time i've left my town since the
pandemic started it was just bizarre to
drive into pittsburgh there wasn't a lot
of traffic there weren't a lot of people
half wearing masks maybe maybe more not
wearing masks than half but uh got the
physical came home and here we are with
pf tpm before we get back to posting
more content at pro footballtalk.com
let's revisit the cam newton contract
that i addressed last night in a special
sunday night go up to your office and
record a video session of pftpm
i was stunned
that was one of those holy crap i look
at my phone first thing i do is make
sure it wasn't a fake account
because when it's a surprise like that
i think that's the normal reaction it's
the first time i've felt that way
since last august
and
retired the first reaction is this fake
and
as i was trying to process that in my
brain 13 year old nephew was over the
house and sitting about 20 feet away
said oh no cam newton to the patriots so
that's when i jumped up came up here and
started working on it been thinking
about it a lot had four hours of car
time today to process it some more look
this is a typical patriots move it's
unexpected on its face even though it
was something that people thought they
should do
it still was something a lot of people
thought bill belichick wouldn't do
i believed that bill belichick should do
it but at the same time i thought he
wouldn't do it because i thought he
wanted to prove that the patriot way
works that the system works that next
man up works the jared stidham who was
there for a year learning from josh
mcdaniels learning from bill belichick
learning from tom brady ready to step
into the job just like brady did in his
second year with the team
so that's what surprising more than
anything else shirley cam newton if
healthy he's a better quarterback surely
without question now is he healthy my
understanding continues to be the
patriots took a leap of faith on that
that
they decided to take the word
of cam newton's agents that cam newton
is healthy and they'll find out when he
shows up and you know what if he's not
healthy there isn't much of a risk here
that's the key
this is the kind of move that only a
bill belichick can make because if it
works he's a genius if it doesn't he's
not an idiot whereas anybody else who
does it if it doesn't work you're an
idiot remember in 2011 after the lockout
what did he do
traded for albert haynesworth and chad
johnson with the thomas chad ochocinco
it didn't work for either one and nobody
ever said boone he gave up draft picks
to get each guy he didn't have to go
draft pick to get cam newton
a top 10 quarterback according to chris
sims
a 2015 nfl mvp a guy who if healthy is
capable of being very very good and yes
is 2-0 all-time
against the new england patriots so
i completely understand why the patriots
did it
and the psychology of it i think is
fascinating
by waiting to make their move they ran
the risk that someone else was going to
sign him but also
they created a circumstance where
if
uh cam newton had no other suitors and
he had no other suitors he was going to
take whatever offer the patriots put out
there
seen a lot of criticism of the contract
comparisons to chase daniel chase daniel
making more than cam newton and jameis
winston combined this year okay fine but
the reality is
neither newton
nor winston had a ton of leverage when
the time came for them to sign their
contract nobody wanted winston to be a
starter people were leery about him
being a backup because he's used to
being a starter he wants to be a starter
chase daniel better fits into that
backup role who will accept his position
and not try to take over that was part
of the i think problem for getting
jameis winston a good backup contract
and then you throw in the fact that cam
newton just wasn't healthy and was a
victim of circumstance a victim of the
panthers not cutting him when they
should have back in february like they
cut greg olsen and the panthers thinking
they can get something in exchange for
cam newton so they held on to him longer
than they should have and then when they
finally cut him there's no fair
opportunity for him to go out and see
what's on the market to get a physical
because of the pandemic so he was stuck
he was stuck and it's unfortunate that
it happened but now he's making chicken
salad he's taking the deal that he can
get so he can get the opportunity to
position himself for next year see if he
doesn't do this deal now
he's going to be in a tough spot to have
the kind of season necessary to make him
an attractive free agent in 2021
he would have been waiting for someone
to get injured
and
look you never know who's going to get
injured who's not going to get injured
you can't predict that what if it's an
injury to a quarterback on a team you
really want to play for or what if
you're not sure how long the injury is
what if it's not season ending but maybe
the guy's going to be out eight weeks do
you go for eight weeks then you have to
worry about being benched for
the starter when he recovers and what if
a team who has an injury to a
quarterback just says next man up we got
a guy who's here who knows the system
this move gets cam newton to new england
to learn the system compete with jared
stidham at a time when student didn't
have an off season program as the number
one guy i mean think about that we've
seen plenty of praise of jared stidham
from patriots players over the past
several months but there's never been a
moment in his time in the nfl where
jared stidham has been the guy in the
locker room full of his peers never been
the guy and now here comes cam newton
who is clearly the guy so it's going to
be easier for newton to compete it's
going to be easier for him to get the
starting job it was smart for him to do
it now i think the patriots knew exactly
what they were doing by waiting i think
they were interested in him all along on
their terms
and they knew that the best way to get
him on their terms was to wait and they
did and they were willing to assume the
risk that he would land somewhere else
and you know what because they never let
on that they wanted him nobody ever
would have said paul the patriots blew
that see that's the value of keeping
your mouth shut
and that's what the patriots do and this
is one of the reasons why they do it
because if you do come off as being too
anxious number one it drives up the
price number two if you don't get the
guy you look like you've lost
instead the patriots look like they've
won and they quite possibly have and cam
newton quite possibly has won as well
depending upon how things go this year
the other victory for the patriots last
night
came from the timing of the leak of the
cam newton contract
because
i i personally think what was going on
the patriots knew that the nfl was going
to leak and then announce the penalties
from last year's spygate three i don't
know how many spy gates there been it's
like rocky movies last year's incident
where
while a camera crew was at a browns
bengals game ostensibly doing a feature
on one of the team's scouts
there was recording of the bengals
sideline just a week before the patriots
were due
to play the bengals
now i still have yet to see anything
suggesting that the patriots football
operations staff had anything to do with
this that there were any connections
remember i said from the get-go
investigate this to determine whether or
not there's any connection between these
video crew and football operations and
if you can't prove it then it's just an
innocent mistake and you know what it
may have been a much smaller penalty if
it had been an innocent mistake
that had been committed by anyone else
but these are the patriots and thanks to
spygate1 spygate 2 which never went
anywhere deflategate that history of
violations resulted in the seven figure
fine and the loss of a third round draft
pick it's a big deal to lose a third
round draft pick it's a big deal to lose
any draft pick so
that was
significant
but
because it was the chaser to the cam
newton news
it got far less play than it ever would
have gotten making the cam newton move
even more brilliant and making me wonder
at some warped level
whether or not they really don't want
cam newton my mother it was just
elaborate pr cover
for the the long delayed resolution to
something that happened more than six
months ago and i never thought they were
going to resolve that one but resolve it
they did and you know they did a little
bit of a favor by holding it until after
the 2020 draft by all
respects this should have been done
before the draft that third round pick
2021 we're worth less than a third round
pick in 2020 especially when we consider
that if there's no college football
season or if they delay it or whatever
it's going to be harder potentially to
scout guys next year those draft picks
may not be as value maybe more of a crap
shoot next year than it typically is all
right uh what else do we want to talk
about how about this
i saw a comment from shaq barrett he's
the guy who
had a decent career in denver not a
superstar goes to tamper for one year
becomes a superstar gets franchised
tagged he's made it clear how long he's
going to stay with the buccaneers he has
recently said
that if he doesn't get a long-term deal
by july 15 he'll sign the franchise
tender
i i got some free advice for shaq
barrett
and and he's guaranteed to get his
money's worth go ahead and sign the
franchise tender now don't run any risk
of the buccaneers deciding to play games
here and remove that tender because i'll
tell you this shaq
if you become a free agent now
june 29 or at any point after today
up to it including july 15. it's gonna
be hard to get the money on the open
market that you would have gotten back
in march and it's gonna be hard to get
that 15.8 million
and
there's no extra leverage that comes
from not having signed the franchise tag
as it relates to a long-term deal
especially when you come out and say
i'm going to sign the franchise tag if i
don't get a long-term deal just sign the
tag sign the tag and protect yourself
against something all it takes is one
crazy moment one wild hair
and that franchise tag gets rescinded
and you're stuck so do what dak prescott
did last week sign the franchise tag get
the 15.8 million in hand and see if it
can be parlayed into a long-term deal by
july 15 and if not it's 15.8 this year
and if you have another big year
they have to give you a 20 raise if they
want to keep you off the open market
next year and that's going to be
close to 20 million dollars for 2021.
all right uh
there's been a lot of talk about what
the nfl is going to do
this season there hasn't been a lot of
guidance there hadn't been a lot of
specificity we're getting
closer and closer to launch of training
camps
getting their rookies early as they
usually do because they're going to be
playing beat the clock just to get
everything ready and in compliance with
the coronavirus guidelines so july 28
we're moving toward that we don't know
what's going to happen in training camp
we don't know what's going to happen
when they start playing games remember i
think the schedule has been constructed
to go forward with week one and then to
have flexibility to either cancel or
postpone weeks two three and four but i
think they fully intend to go forward
with week one and see what happens and i
don't know that let's see what happens
is the right way to deal with this
pandemic i'd like to think there are
better plans in place other than well
here's our plan let's see if it works
you want to be confident it's going to
work and i understand in this specific
situation there's no all the confidence
that anything is going to work but i
mention all of that number one because
people care and i get asked all the time
is it going to be football this year and
my honest answer my only answer is i
don't know
i talked to some people who are very
high up on the nfl's food chain and they
say absolutely positively you talk to
other people and they're like we don't
know
that's the thing at some point now and
and i've i've advised the league office
to begin
to more regularly
communicate information to people in the
media about what the plans are for 2020
so we can then provide that information
to the fans and so people can start to
be confident and crickets nothing so
it's not just for the fans and for the
media
the players and the coaches have to be
feeling some anxiety and some
uncertainty you know i i'm a guy who
likes to have everything planned out
and the idea that there's this
this day out there that is only
30 days away july 28th and i don't know
am i going to training camp and i don't
know
how the the
procedures are going to work nobody's
told me anything the closer that gets
the more agitated i'd be getting and i
think a lot of players and coaches are
going to feel the same way so i think it
it behooves the nfl
to start making concrete plans striking
agreements with the nflpa where it
needed and get information into the
hands and the minds of the people who
have to process this new reality and get
themselves ready for it you need time to
get your brain wrapped around what your
life is going to look like on a day in
and day out basis you don't want to just
get thrust into that so i continue to
encourage the nfl let your people know
what you're going to do because it sure
seems like a lot of people
in the nfl with the teams are in the
dark now mark davis the raiders owner
recently suggested and these were
comments that were made to the las vegas
review journal as part of an article
that primarily was focused on mark
davis's intense objection to putting
tarp over the first eight rows of the
seats at his new stadium you know he's
got this new toy and he can't fully play
with it right it's like you got this new
toy that you've wanted forever
and one of the pieces is broken and you
got to send away to the company that
made it to send that piece so until then
you've got a toy that is missing one of
its pieces and it pisses you off i can't
remember what toy it was for me but
haven't we all been there this toy that
we really want we get it and something's
broken and we try to make do with what
we have that's mark davis with his new
stadium something's broken he can't have
seats in the first eight rows and he's
mad about it well in that same article
he pointed out that
they may have to do a bubble concept by
the time it's all said and done it's one
thing to protect players from fans but
how do you protect players from players
and maybe their best bet is to do a
bubble approach look i don't think a
bubble approach is going to work and
it's definitely not going to work
if you are coming up with a bubble
approach on the fly like it can't be
plan b
bubbles got to be plan a if you're going
to pull bubble off bubble is playing
a and bubble was put in place three
months ago when they didn't begin to
make the plans for a bubble
that put them on the path toward
a non-bubble environment and i wrote
about it march 29th people thought i was
crazy you take everybody to a remote
location you you build enough fields to
play six seven games simultaneously you
have a whole complex there you build
dormitories look it's not going to be
cheap it's not going to be easy and it's
not something you can throw together on
a moment's notice but that's the best
bubble
for the nfl because there's too many
people there's too many people who would
break the bubble you need a true bubble
to make it work for the nfl if they
would take all the teams to las vegas
maybe that's why mark davis is
suggesting the possibility of a bubble
approach maybe he wants to host the nfl
in vegas this year how do you keep
everyone in the bubble
think about it 65 players per team
coaches
support staff family members presumably
presumably they'll have family members
there you're gonna you're gonna pull
these guys away from their families for
four months
and and and and dare suggest the
possibility of a pay cut when you're
doing that to them there's gonna be guys
who bust out of that bubble nightclub 10
minutes away whatever the case may be
and then if they get the virus there and
they bring it back to the bubble you got
a problem so i just don't think the
bubble is practical and i think if the
nfl finds itself
thinking about a bubble on the fly
if you're in that position where you're
having those thoughts you need to do
that the better approach may be just to
pull the plug and be done with it and i
hope it doesn't come to that i have been
rooting for months for football to
happen there's a group out there that
seems to think not like an organized
group as far as i know but there's
there's a collection of individuals of
like mine they think that anyone who
points out the things that the nfl
should be worried about in order to pull
off the season those people are rooting
against the season well no i
we're rooting against the nfl being as
oblivious as way too many people walking
around without masks are because if
football season doesn't happen one of
the big reasons is going to be too many
people were
either too selfish or too dumb to comply
with the guidelines and do the things
aimed at slowing or eliminating the
spread of the virus period
period
so get mad at those of us who have been
saying what about this what about this
you need to think about this you need to
think about that
and go ahead and be
be blissful in your ignorance
because those of you who decided that
this was simply the flu those of you who
decided to listen to the charlatans out
there who are trying to make a buck by
telling you what you want to hear you
know sometimes
we must eat vegetables we can't have
candy
sometimes we need to pass on the candy
well you've got these folks out there
just force feeding candy to the people
who want to feel like they're okay that
they're not jerks
for failing to do the things that
they're supposed to do
and that's part of the problem it's part
of the problem and the folks in the
media who have been pushing that bs
special place in hell as far as i'm
concerned i hope i'm not there to
witness it i
i hope i'm not there to say man he's
really got it rough oh wait uh anyway um
that's all i got to say about the bubble
approach it's it's i'm concerned
but i'm still consciously optimistic
and uh
i hope they get it figured out
i think that's i think they
i think they have a plan
that they genuinely believe will work
i just think that there are a lot of
variables there
and they're they're taking
not quite the same leap of faith the
patriots are taking with cam newton
but they're hoping that certain things
break their way in order to pull off
the 2020 season amid the pandemic one
last thing to point out before we wrap
this up today
today is the 37th anniversary of the
death of joe delaney he was the chief's
running back who had a huge rookie
season in 1981 1982 he was banged up a
little bit june 29 1983 only 24 years
old with three small children at home
joe delaney was at a park in louisiana
there was a pond
and
there was some sort of a safety hazard
like the water it was a
treacherous drop off or something but
three kids got into that water
and they were struggling and joe delaney
couldn't swim
but that did not stop him while a bunch
of other people were standing around
joe delaney got into that water to try
to save
those three boys he saved one
two of them drowned with joe delaney but
it's a story that i feel compelled to
tell every june 29 on the website and in
any video or audio setting that we may
have because
for whatever reason
like some of the great nfl stories
we all know about no matter how old or
young we are
and young passionate football fans
become aware
of you know like the catch for example
or
the immaculate reception like
there's enough of it out there that it
enters the consciousness of a football
fan even if it's a young football fan
but every year every year without fail i
hear from people who say
i didn't know about joe delandy
and
look i don't know what the nfl needs to
do
to make joe delaney more
of a part of what football fans become
exposed to i'm doing my part every year
every june 29 i'm going to talk about it
i'm going to write about actually had a
story yesterday because a monument was
unveiled over the weekend near that pond
in louisiana
and people just need to know the story
ultimate selflessness
ultimate
heroic act ultimate bravery
and
there's just so many
story my heart breaks for the kids who
drowned my heart was for the child who
survived the survivor's guilt that he
must have had his entire life
unfathomable when you go into that pond
with your two friends
and they don't come out and the man who
comes in to save the three of you
doesn't come out and you do good luck
living with that your entire life
um and then the three young children
you know i try to put myself in the
shoes of those girls
and it would be hard if you're the if
you're the children
to not be mad
at your father and and think you you
chose three strangers over us
um
but i don't think it's you know joe
delaney was a hero because
he didn't engage in that analysis
if he had
like most of us would have
see that becomes an excuse to not try to
help
and i guarantee you if i was in his spot
june 29 1983 there's no way in hell i'm
jumping into that pond
that's why i'm in awe
of what joe delaney did and that's why i
feel compelled every year to share with
you
and anyone who reads a website the story
of joe delaney um a triumph and a
tragedy all wrapped into one i'll never
forget where i was
when i heard about it
i've told this story before i just
graduated high school a few weeks
earlier sitting at the kitchen table
with a bowl of cereal flipping through
the newspaper and i saw the story
and my heart sank my jaw dropped and uh
um you know it stayed with me all these
years and i'm just glad i have a
platform where we can tell the story of
joe delaney we encourage others to find
out more about joe delaney and and maybe
and hopefully
we'll get to the point
where
when we remember joe delaney every year
there isn't somebody who says you know
i've never heard about joe delaney
before
all right uh that's it for today's pft
pm we'll be back tomorrow it's easy it's
easy all i got to do see i you can't
really if you look behind me
it's typically a mess in here
right
uh so i just kind of take everything and
like push it so it's out of the screen
here and anything maybe on the floor i
get push it over there so i kind of have
a little mountain going just out of shot
over there but but this is nice this
forces me to keep at least some area of
my office
looking like a professional or something
close to an office all right thanks for
your time
profitabletalk.com even though the
show's off and we act like it's a
vacation
it's not work i freely admit it's not
work really i just sat here for the last
25 minutes and just talked about
whatever i want to talk about boy that's
a rough day i'm gonna write some stories
about whatever i'm interested in that's
a rough day i'll get back to doing that
and thank you for allowing me to have
this life where i really don't have to
work we'll keep trying to do what we can
do to keep you up to date on everything
happening in the national football
league and we'll talk to you again
tomorrow have a great day
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports